Space travel. It’s one of humanity’s most truly
miraculous achievements: Building the technology
to defy gravity and journey into the stars above,
a place our ancestors could only dream of going.
Throughout history, humans have found gods and
heroes in the constellations, and today when
we look up into the sky, we have the privilege
of knowing that flesh-and-blood mortals live
up there alongside them. It’s a humbling,
inspirational, and downright awesome thing.
But, of course, there’s always going to be
naysayers. People who just want to rain on
our interstellar parade. And nobody fits this
bill harder than people affected by an anomalous
phenomenon classified by the SCP Foundation as
SCP-2001, the “Space Oddity.” And before you ask,
no, the late David Bowie is not and never has
been an SCP. To truly understand this anomaly,
we need to take a look at three different people
who are affected by it to varying degrees.
Let’s start with your friend, Kevin.
Even if you don’t have a friend called
Kevin, you definitely have at least a
casual acquaintance just like him. Kevin is a
very confident man with plenty of ill-informed
opinions he’d be more than happy to argue
about until the heat death of the universe.
He’s the kind of guy who can turn a discussion
about your favorite movie into World War
III. But you never knew until recently that
he held such strong opinions on space travel.
One day, you were discussing the latest rocket
launch with a mutual friend of yours while
Kevin just happened to be in earshot. The
second you start talking about how exciting
it’ll be to one day put a person on Mars, he
swaggers over, face twisted into a grimace.
You’re already preparing for him
to say something cringe inducing,
and Kevin being Kevin, he doesn’t disappoint.
“Ugh, don’t tell me you two dweebs are talking
about space travel. What a stupid waste of money.
You guys know there’s nothing but rocks up there,
right? Aliens don’t exist. It’s all just another
excuse for dumb scientists to waste my tax dollars
on playing with their stupid toys. How about you
two talk about something that really matters?”
You may be thinking Kevin is just a jerk, and he
definitely is, but he’s also a victim. A victim of
SCP-2001. You see, 2001 is described as an
anomalous series of neural oscillations that occur
during three of the four stages of sleep. Namely,
NREM - or “Non-Rapid Eye Movement” - Sleep. During
one of these three stages, the amygdala, a part
of the brain also known as “The Lizard Brain”,
enters a heightened state of activity for ten to
fifteen minutes. Once the process has started,
even waking up the affected individual will
do nothing to stop the actual infection.
There are no traits that predispose people
to SCP-2001 infection. It appears to infect
people in equal measures regardless of age,
gender, and race. Spectrographic analysis on
the afflicted has shown that the condition may
not be intraneural - meaning, originating within
the brain - and may actually be the product of
an outside influence. The invariable effect of
SCP-2001 is the infected developing negative
feelings towards the concept of space travel,
in increasing gradations of severity depending
on which stage of NREM sleep the anomaly began
to take effect. Of real concern to the Foundation
is that SCP-2001 seems to be manifesting with
increasing frequency in astronomers, astronauts,
and individuals who otherwise deal with space.
The SCP-2001 case manifests
in three different varieties:
Gamma, Beta, and Alpha. Each variety has
its own unique traits and idiosyncrasies.
We’ve encountered a Gamma type already - your
dear friend, Kevin. This is the most mild type
of SCP-2001 infection, and also the most common,
affecting at least 1% of the global population.
It occurs for those who were infected during
the second stage of NREM sleep. People with
Gamma-Type SCP-2001 infection will, for the
most part, seem like their normal selves,
save for a disparaging attitude towards the
concept of space travel. Whenever it’s brought up,
they’ll likely complain and change the subject
immediately, but it won’t affect their behavior
too much overall. The same cannot be said
for people with Beta-Type SCP-2001 infection.
Meet Riley. You’ve never spoken to Riley before,
but she’s a young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe, often seen frantically typing on
her laptop. You assume she’s writing a screenplay
or a novel, but in fact, she’s posting
simultaneously on multiple conspiracy forums.
Among her favorite theories are that the earth is
flat, space is a hologram, and the moon landing
was faked by Stanley Kubrick, director of such
films as The Shining and, appropriately, 2001:
A Space Odyssey. You made the heinous mistake of
going to your local cafe at the same time as Riley
one morning, while wearing a NASA baseball cap.
An error that you would come to regret deeply.
You bought a latte and decided to sit down
for a moment, just the briefest little rest,
but that was all the time Riley needed.
Her eyes seemed to burn with hatred.
You asked if there was anything you
could do to help her, and she responded.
“You’re just buying into the propaganda. Do
you have any idea what NASA really stands for?
It’s ‘Never A Straight Answer.’ All their
supposed achievements - the moon landing,
the ISS, dehydrated astronaut food - it’s all a
big sham! NASA is just a slush fund for corrupt
government officials, no human has ever been able
to survive in space. It’s too dangerous - anyone
sent up there will die immediately, no exceptions.
And even if they did it would be pointless,
space is just a dark, infinite void that goes on
forever. It’s just a big pile of dangerous lies!”
Feeling awkward, you decide to just get up and
leave. That’s when Riley grabs your NASA cap
right off of your head and throws it in
the trash. That’s fine, you don’t intend
on going back for it. You just keep walking,
trying your best to move calmly out the door.
Wise decision, because Riley is
actually a Beta-Type SCP-2001
infectee. As you can probably tell, Beta
cases are a lot more severe than Gamma cases,
and people infected with them seem to come off
as deranged conspiracy theorists with a rabid
hatred of all space travel. They’ll form elaborate
fantasies about the falsification of space travel,
and will often decry it as too pointless
or dangerous to ever be undertaken.
But of course, the danger of Beta-Types pale
in comparison to Alpha-Types. These are people
infected by SCP-2001 during REM sleep, the stage
of sleep typically associated with dreaming.
As a result, its effects on the mind are far
more dangerous and profound. Take, for instance,
the tragic case of SCP Foundation Junior
Researcher Martinez. He was one of the many
operatives stationed at Foundation Outpost-12,
a complex that works in coordination with NASA
to launch both manned and unmanned missions into
space on behalf of the Foundation’s interests.
It’s a valuable asset to the Foundation in
investigating and combating space-based anomalies.
Martinez, who had previously spent time
working with SCP-2001 infected D-Classes,
was part of ground control, something that
would prove to be a literally fatal oversight
on the part of the Foundation. During the
early stages of takeoff for a manned craft,
Martinez seened to become extremely agitated.
Over time this agitation steadily increased,
and eventually became a full-on breakdown
as the rocket ascended. He pulled out some
kind of strange, anomalous control device, and
began disrupting the operations of the rocket.
Martinez was shot dead by
guards as a defensive measure,
but it was already too late. The craft exploded,
and everyone on board was tragically killed.
Later investigations into the incident found a
crucial piece of evidence tying Junior Researcher
Martinez to SCP-2001. They discovered a journal
entry he’d written shortly before his breakdown,
which seemed to have been written in a
completely different style to prior entries,
implying that some kind of massive
psychological shift had occurred.
The following is the contents
of that journal entry.
”I wish to state first that my mind
and body are perfectly sound. I am
prepared to submit myself to any and
all tests to prove that I'm clean.
I have the answer to SCP-2001.
Just yesterday, during an interview
with an Alpha-infected D-Class,
I was asked a question that stopped my mind for
a minute. The woman I was interviewing asked me
if I knew the Foundation was right. I said no, I
wasn't sure. Then she asked me, what if we were
right. I could only assume that by "we", she meant
2001 carriers. I said nothing for a while, and
then she spoke. She told me of a dream she'd had a
while ago. She said that something talked to her,
told her about how dangerous outer space was. It
showed her the beasts that roam the void between
stars, about the fractal beings that absorb the
very fabric of reality, about the… this part
of the entry was expunged… that we're keeping
in that godforsaken door. And she was scared.
She told me that at the end of the dream,
as she woke up, it told her what it was.
It's all of space.
Space fears for us. We're living, breathing
lifeforms, and space loves us and cherishes us.
She asked me if I had any idea what the chances
of intelligent life forming on another planet are,
then she told me a number that took a
minute and a half to recite. By this point,
I couldn't speak. I started thinking:
about the demographics of infection,
about the symptoms, about more expunged data
here... and suddenly, it all made sense. Some
of the things she said stuck in my brain, and
they all added up to the same thing: that we
are in grave danger if we go out there. We can't
go out there. We can't go out there. We can't.
There's a reason behind SCP-2001, and it's nowhere
near as terrifying as all of my colleagues think.
Space wants to protect us. There are things
out there that would wipe humanity clean off
of this plane of existence, and we are
too precious to our mother, to our host,
to the universe we live in, for
her to allow that to happen.
What I am going to do tomorrow
is not a result of infection.
It is not a result of madness. It is not a result
of anything other than purest knowledge. You see,
I've found out the truth. And it's more
beautiful than I ever could have dreamed.”
Given what Martinez would later go on to do, it’s
clear that he wasn’t in as sound a state of mind
as he thought. As you’ve probably already
gathered, people suffering from Alpha-Type
SCP-2001 infection will do anything they can to
actively prevent or sabotage attempts at space
travel. This is a minor concern when it comes to
civilians, but when it infects people who actually
work in these fields - like Junior Researcher
Martinez - it can have devastating results.
But this isn’t where this story ends.
While it’s currently extremely classified,
there is actually a fourth category of SCP-2001
infection, discovered in the wake of Martinez’s
death. A key element of the Alpha strain is that
it cannot cause people to perform acts that they
would find immoral, such as murdering the entire
crew of a manned shuttle with a crash. However,
the fourth category - known as Alpha-Prime
- does away with any moral compunctions
whatsoever. People infected with this virus will
prevent space travel by any means necessary.
And unlike other SCP-2001 infections, you
aren’t compromised in your sleep this time.
The vector for infection is simply talking to
someone infected with the regular Alpha strain,
and hearing a few key trigger phrases. That’s
how Junior Researcher Martinez caught it
from the D-Classes he was working with. What
are these key phrases? We still don’t know.
But if you find that you suddenly
have much stronger opinions about
space travel than you’ve ever had
before, try to keep them to yourself.
Now check out “SCP-096 - Looking at
a picture of the Shy Guy in space?
SCP-096 Questions and Theories”
and “SCP-5000 - Why? The Full Compilation”
for more fascinating Foundation facts!